the biopic Bohemian Rhapsody brings a
story of Queen and Freddie Mercury to
life on the big screen but how much of
what you see in the movie is the band's
real life and how much is just fantasy
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm revealing the six
biggest differences between the Bohemian
Rhapsody movie and the true story of
Queen and their charismatic frontman
keep watching to the end to find out how
the movie changed Freddie Mercury's real
life look and hit the bell to keep up to
date with all my new videos according to
the movie Freddie Mercury or Farooq
balsora as he was then first met Brian
May and Roger Taylor after seeing them
perform on stage with herb and smile
that same night smiles lead singer Tim
Staffel decided he'd had enough of the
band going nowhere and quit so mercury
offered his own singing and songwriting
services and after a quick demo of his
vocal talents Mae and Taylor agreed in
reality however things happened rather
differently as Freddie Mercury and
smiles lead singer Tim Staffel were
actually friends at Ealing Art College
where they both studied and it was
Staffel who introduced mercury to Brian
May and Roger Taylor in the late 1960s
mercury was keen to be the band's lead
singer so when staefel left smile in
1970 mercury was perfectly positioned to
take over the filmmakers probably went
from more condensed version of how Queen
got together as they didn't want to
spend too much time on the band's
build-up but instead focus on their
years as a group by the way Tim staff
will actually got back together with Mae
and Taylor to re-record smile song doing
all right for the movie in the film we
see Queens lead guitarist Brian May
showing the rest of the band his idea
for the classic anthem we will rock you
in a recording studio sometime in 1980
and soon after queen are shown playing
the new song on stage at Madison Square
Garden
now while the band did perform we will
rock you at that famous New York Arena
in 1984 I may actually wrote the iconic
song several years earlier and in fact
it appeared on queens album news of the
world in 1977 the most visually striking
issue with this scene in the movie is
that in reality when Queen first
performed we will rock you in 1977
Freddie Mercury didn't have a mustache
and had shoulder-length
perm but because the film moves the
song's composition to 1980 we see
mercury
in the studio with the short hair
mustache he sported from that time much
is made in the movie of how Mercury's
desire for a solo career broke the band
up however back in the real world
according to Brian May they all tried to
leave the band more than once
and in fact Mercury wasn't even the
first member of Queen to release a solo
album that was drummer Roger Taylor
whose album of fun in space came out in
1981 and two years later in 1983 even
though Quinn did take a break from
performing live
they still recorded a new album together
also during that period Taylor made a
second solo album and Brian May released
a mini-album too as for Mercury solo
offerings he released a number of
singles and two albums over the years
including Barcelona and mr. bad guy in
the movie after the band agree to get
back together they say we haven't played
together in years it's kind of suicide
to play again for the first time in
front of millions in real life though
that just wasn't the case as Live Aid
took place in mid-july 1985 and Queen
had actually been on tour together from
August 1984 to mid-may 1985 with their
latest album the works
I imagine the filmmakers made this big
change in order to raise the stakes for
the band's Live Aid performance and make
their show-stealing set look less like a
foregone conclusion or more like an
uphill behind-the-scenes struggle one of
the benefits of this change from
real-life Queen is that it airbrush is
out some controversial moments in their
history such as performances an
apartheid era South Africa during a
United Nations boycott and a musician's
union ban I wouldn't expect to see
something like that in an official
biopic but some reviewers have
criticized the film overall for feeling
rather sanitized probably due to the
band's heavy involvement as producers in
another departure from reality the film
has mercury finding out he has AIDS and
telling his bandmates about his illness
shortly before Live Aid in mid 1985 in
the real world mercury was reportedly
diagnosed with AIDS in 1987 two years
after Live Aid and told his bandmates
sometime after that it seems like the
filmmakers made this timeline change as
they wanted to use the Live Aid concert
to frame the film and finish the movie
on a huge high note for the band while
still recognizing some of what happened
after that by bringing Mercury's
diagnosis forward by several years the
film deliberately dials up the poignancy
of both the lyrics he sang and his
performance but the choice to cram so
many events into one day from mercury
tracking down his future partner -
coming out to his parents - performing
at Live Aid turns this sequence into
something of an exposition dump
prosthetic teeth and artificial nose and
a whole variety of wigs and fake
mustaches which as some of the items
used to help actor Rami Malek look like
Freddie Mercury for the movie one thing
the film's makeup and her department
didn't use though was colored contacts
to change Malik's light-colored eyes -
Mercury's dark ones it's perhaps a
little odd that they didn't do that so I
wonder if Malick couldn't wear them for
some reason I remember Madonna saying
the colored contacts she wore for a V -
are pretty uncomfortable and hard to get
used to for example or maybe the
Bohemian Rhapsody filmmakers decided
matching Mercury's eye color just wasn't
a big deal after all the movies hair and
makeup designer said you don't
necessarily want them to look exactly
alike but you do want to catch the
essence of the person either way a
difference in eye color obviously isn't
as important as finding an actor who can
bring mercury to life convincingly on
screen a Malick has certainly been
getting great reviews for his role in
the film so what did you think of
Bohemian Rhapsody did any of these
changes bother you and did you spot any
others tapleft to watch another Bohemian
Rhapsody video or tap write for another
video you're sure to like if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate a thumbs up and
a share thanks for watching and see you
next time you PK movie lovers